all right it is the end of days yep
friends someone actually bet that you
were gonna say that that's gonna say
it's the end of days yeah the world's
coming to an end well Yellowstone is a
chunk chunk of Yellowstone the size of
Chicago has been pulsing why an
injection of magma under Norris Geyser
Basin may be why the region is five
inches higher today than it was twenty
years ago so is it really the end of
days now I don't know how would I know
I'm not a seismologist or at Yellowstone
ologist but they do say that Yellowstone
blows its top every five hundred
thousand years
yeah and we're coming up on that I guess
are we no no no we're way past it oh
gosh yeah that says right here
no oh maybe I don't know if that's the
actual 640 thousand years oh man in
northwestern Wyoming yeah in the center
of Yellowstone National Park a bubbling
called Dara is the scar there was 640
thousand year old gargantuan volcanic
eruption the 3472 square mile park what
encompassing the caldera is filled with
geological wonder lands and sprouting
geysers and effervescing pools all
ultimately driven by magma and the
superheat fluids churning in the rock
below the surface is that like the butt
hole of the earth and it's gonna just
like no it's gonna fart when they put it
that way that's amazing thank you though
for that comparison one of these areas
Norris Geyser Basin to the northwest of
the caldera contains more than 500 high
mothur hydrothermal features these
tempestuous geysers and pools often
change from day to day but a much larger
transformation has been taking place as
well for for more than two decades an
area larger than Chicago centered near
the basin has been inflating and
deflating by several inches in erratic
bursts in a hyperactive volcanic region
like Yellowstone the exact cause of any
specific movement are difficult to pin
down but a recent study in the journal
of geophysical research solid earth may
help explain why this pocket of land has
been breathing in and out
in all likelihood and now here's where
he gets our he simmers down our hopes of
a true and Yellowstone apocalypse oh
good and all likelihood Norris has been
a center of deformation for a very long
time said Daniel Duras an der
eisendrache
dizzer Eisen I can't pronounce that name
our research geologist the US geological
surveys cascades Volcano Observatory and
one of the co-authors of the new
research scientists used decades of
satellite based radar and GPS data on
Norris Geyser Basin to model what may
have occurred below its surface based on
the changes above in the late 1990s a
body of magma intruded beneath Norris
and fluids trapped within the magma
bubbled out and made their way through
the rocky labyrinth above them as the
fluids got stuck in the pressure buildup
the ground would rise and when the
fluids were able to escape elsewhere the
ground deflated today magma derived
fluids could sit close to the surface
just a mile or so below the ground with
that being said I think we're getting
into the nitty-gritty of national
Geographics science mumbo-jumbo and I'd
rather talk about the world blowing up
so Yellowstone a man I was eating that
up I love that science money it's fun
it's fun but I think about it I think we
get the point they say the the new
research does not indicate the
supervolcano that created Yellowstone's
caldera which erupted 640,000 years ago
is any more likely to erupt now okay
instead the movements may help explain
weather why the parks steamboat geyser
has been erupting at a record-breaking
pace since March 2018 researchers also
speculate that the changes below Norris
may mean a slightly increased chance of
hydrothermal explosion taking place in
the basin so look well the Clyde the
notorious and I notice that they don't
say anything about with the history of
Earth that we know of it erupted every
five hundred thousand years not just
like supervolcano yeah yeah man before
that five hundred thousand years and
before that five hundred thousand years
so that's kind of like been the way it's
been and it's been six hundred forty
thousand years so we're a hundred and
forty thousand years are over overdue
for this volcano to explode I mean can
it just happen it's the waiting I can't
stay I mean if it did happen America
would be gone we would totally oh yeah
and then it because it's so massive I'm
pretty sure the fallout would pretty
much go around the world unless you're a
billionaire in your mountain bunker in
New Zealand yeah but how long do they
gonna last five or ever ten years no
forever what do you mean yeah I don't
know they have like 50 year supplies of
energy and food and those things that is
that it's like summer does that realest
amount of time they're pushing the limit
what's what's the half-life for like a
nuclear
I'm like 35 years I don't know if that
long yeah yeah a long time there you go
so when Yellowstone blows up what you do
you just sit here and wait for like the
shock wave and the acid rain to come
just like I don't think you there's
nothing we can do somebody somebody's
confident commented in the super chats
that they would run towards the blast
release I don't think you can run like
if you're in New York what do you do run
a mile just start jogging towards are
jogging days you'll get hit by the shock
wave or something yeah but actually is
something my dad use to say he would say
if you saw a nuclear bomb coming
straight down to like Chicago mm-hmm
what do you do and what would you do
like if you were if you were in the city
I would quickly take a picture and post
it on Instagram okay that I was there
the point was that there's there's
different levels of the blast radius of
okay certain nuclear bomb and if you're
in like the you mouth to death radius
yeah you would much prefer to be in the
non vaporized instantly radius yeah we
vaped and like the person in New York
running towards it would more likely be
choked to death by the Ash right right
you know in the fallout from the volcano
Wow probably what most of Ronnie country
would be running towards Yellowstone
wouldn't change anything you're gonna
choke on ash yes I'm gonna blot it out
and then you're gonna you're gonna you
know acid rain or whatever mm but if it
was like a nuclear bomb you wouldn't
know which way to run most people trying
to run away from it yeah and then you
could end up running into the you mouth
to death zone right yeah you know it's
crazy is like I'm pretty sure we put we
made the bombs radioactive on purpose we
worked like to maximize lingering damage
yeah it's crazy
Ravens are messed up yeah so
unfortunately there is no increased
likelihood Yellowstone erupts humanity
so you know I mean we've been wishing
for the the giant meteor of death to
come in and yeah sweep us away to our
sweet dreams fortunate I'm kidding by
the way but not not Yellowstone either
it's interesting though when you see
stories like this because naturally the
speculation is gonna be about this
there's some story about this woman
someone posted in the super chat the
other day her name is I think like Mitch
Rana
Soldo or something yeah is that did you
did you look at I did look it up and she
just looks kind of like a scam she's
like an Eastern European lady who claims
at the virgin
Mary visits her every second day of a
month or something yeah at some point
throughout the month and so what ends up
happening is and you see these stories
all the time I'm not saying this one
deserves any special credence but she's
saying like this was the last visit so
you combine that with everything
happening yellowstone's pulsating the
stars are aligning J this literally
aligning yeah I think I read this one
that Mars Jupiter said in a crescent
moon will appear very close together
the earliest spring equinox in 124 years
I don't even know what that means but
the world's ending but people like so so
there's like crazy viral posts about the
apocalypse happening okay like they
think the government is being purged
right now the world is sending to chaos
the global pandemic is is way worse it's
like you know I got to be honest I
actually love all these crazy
conspiracies there's fun to read yeah
you know nothing ever really happens to
exciting but I'll tell you what when
we're in the midst of this global crisis
where we're told we can't go outside
that's it's it's fun to entertain you
know maybe there could be something else
going on we don't know about and I'll
give a specific example when we read
that story the other day where Tucker
said Tucker Carlson was talking to a
government intelligence agent who said
China was not telling the truth yeah so
there's probably a bunch of crazy stuff
happening right now now back to the
point about Yellowstone remember the
member that would be 2012 and like the
Denver tomorrow I just haven't seen it
so long I want to go watch from now I'm
just imagining right now they're
trending so you've got like Trump and
pence and foul Chee and how much people
are like they're walking very like
quickly through the White House and then
someone hands a report and like here's
what's really happening and they look
through it and they're like dear God
it's bad
true we are not the main stars of the
movie of the simulation you know I mean
like here's what I was thinking about um
I think this may have been a TV show or
something had an idea for a game a video
game where you actually watch the main
characters and you play kind of as an
NPC interesting like so what what I mean
is what the idea is that the story
scenario doesn't involve you at all okay
so it's like you're it's like I'm
engineer playing GTA and the game's
story is progressing without you and
you're like standing then also just like
a plane crash and then like an action
hero like spy jumps off the roof and
like
grappling hooks away and you're just
like you're doing other stuff okay
yeah so that's how I feel like we are
right now all right
we're sitting here going log just
sitting here while his crazy stuff is
going on and we have no idea what's
really happening and for all we know
it's crazier than we could imagine I
think if the government's reacting the
way they are it's probably a lot crazier
than we realized
yeah I think it is like what's the
likelihood that's not crazy at all in
there lying you know I mean like what
they really sacrifice billions in
profits and it all stuff for like this
global catastrophe no they love their
profits I love their power they do it
how did they give it up yeah they went
like New York was down for two days or
something for whatever reason I don't
know like four years ago and like
everybody freaked out they're like wow
we lost so much revenue like we got to
get everything back up and running
because without without this revenue
like the city can't function and they
like now everything's shut down so
here's what I'm saying right you know
I'm not a conspiracy skeptical okay
we've got the pulsating Chicago sighs
the basin sure it's probably just
pulsing I don't think about it it's
overdue by one and 40,000 year it's blow
up we've got the planets lining up in a
strange way with the earliest Equinox I
do like that it's Chicago sighs that's
cool too nah I don't know if anyone knew
this Tim is from Chicago but but combine
this with like gun sales chaos like when
like whatever is happening it's
happening you know I mean like cue the
Ron Paul meme you know the Ron Paul meme
where he's like it's happening yeah like
the lights are flashing yeah yeah man
we're in it and you know I guess it's
kind of exciting I wouldn't be surprised
if like if aliens showed up at this
point like a [ __ ] just came down I'd be
like not surprised in the least bit I
want it just just a Louis I just the
truth really yeah well that's the type
of person I am though I'd always
appreciate the truth over for sure being
tossed around whatever so what do you
think about this Yellowstone thing just
I mean I've always I've already known
about Yellowstone for a while now that
it's overdue but it's not no it's
nothing new that it's changing that it's
rising and falling that's that's been
going on so it's not you this this
you know article is just like okay I
mean no that's the way it's been it's
almost like they're like ooh
I can add some more hysteria out there
no I think worry about it a little bit
National Geographic isn't doing that mm
maybe well maybe not purposely but you
know what man our our the duration of
our lives individually it's like let
it's a it's a blink of an eye in this
Universal timeline yeah you know so
we're talking with hundreds of thousands
of years we could live generations and
never see it yeah and it wouldn't be
that big a deal the deviation would only
be like oh it's like a 20 percent
deviation it's not even that big of a
deal but one day it'll happen what does
that mean does it mean all life on the
planet swiped out permanently or does it
mean it's gonna be the next big
extinction event and then so hey
whatever whatever whatever little kid is
playing this game this this sim eartha
for whatever plague inc and they're
gonna be alike I'm bored with this one
purge and then make like a new world of
lizard people yeah you know whatever do
you think I guess mm-hmm yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you